اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الدفاع
الجوي الروسي رصد يوم 20 مارس قد اتين
استراتيجيتين امريكيتين من طراز
b52 تحلقان باتجاه الحدود الروسيه فوق بحر
البلطيق وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان مقاتله
روسيه من طراز سخوي 35 اقلعت الاعتراض
القذيفتين اللتين لم تنتهك الحدود الروسيه
وعدت الى قاعدتها بعد ابتعاد القذفتين
الامريكيتين حسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لمزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من موسكو
مدير مكتب الجزيره زاور شاوج زاور في اي
سياق تضع روسيا هذا التحرك العسكري الجوي
الاعتراض
المقاتلتين الامريكيتين
نعم حسنا تضعه في سياق ماركه
اضرار بامن روسيا من قبل قوات حلف شمال
الاطلسي بدا قبل حتى العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا ربما عادت هذه
الاعتراضات تتكرر في الاونه الاخيره حسن
والتي كنا نشهدها منذ عام 2018
بشكل كبير في فوق البحر البلطيق وفوق
البحر الاسود اضافه الى منطقه المحيط
الهادئ في اقصى الشارقه الروسي ربما هذا
التحليق التحليق
لطائرتين استراتيجيتين امريكيتين من طراز
ب 52 هي
واضح انه يشكل تهديدا للامن الروسي خاصه
وانا
من طراز هذه الطائرات حلقت في الاسبوع
الماضي في ثلاث
طلعات فوق الدول البلطيق استونيلات
والاستوانيا بالقرب من الحدود الروسيه اذا
كنا نعلم انها تبعد يعني تبعد هذه الدول
فعليا تقع على حدود مستوى تبعد مسافه ليست
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو وبالتالي ايضا
اهميه هذه هذا الحادث اليوم هو اعتراض
ربما لم يؤدي الى مواجهه انه ياتي بعد
ايام قليله من ازمه كبيره اندلعت بين
روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
خلفيه سقوط امر اسقاط
للمسيره الامريكيه فوق البحر الاسود شكرا
جزيلا لك زور شاويش مدير مكتب الجزيره في
موسكو